oh
whoa
wow
holy cow oh holy oh
oh man
wow oh
dude i don't know
nice freaking phenomenal happy happy
abby randy you're huge
wow no that's not it oops this might be
one of the best unboxings we've done
here
[Music]
what's up guys back in the geek culture
studios uh with something pretty
effing amazing if i may say so myself
this is from queen studios
this is thanos
from avengers end game quarter scale
which we really don't know a quarter
scale is because we really don't know
how big thanos actually is
but it's this is big
35 kgs
of thanos
in this box officially marvel licensed
as you can tell
by the box here
this looks
freaking awesome
awesome i mean we've been doing
gauntlets here from hasbro and various
other companies from china and they're
all cool
this
is on another level so i'm going to
unbox this i'm going to have some help
randy here from collector's arc who is
actually the distributor in singapore
he's going to help me unbox it as well
there's i think about 14 pieces to put
it together it's made out of polystone
so it's a little bit more durable than
resin
and we are going to put thanos together
and display it for you here in the geek
culture studio this is a world's first
only
776 pieces made
of this in the premium edition
that's it we've got one of 776 here
i'm pumped for this man this is uh
35 kg we're gonna put it
forget that you're gonna have to get put
on the dining table
just kick a family member out of house
thanos belongs there anyway let's unbox
this bad boy randy come on in buddy
come on in
let's uh help me bring this down to the
table
oh this is guys honestly speaking this
is really heavy
holy [ __ ]
i can say right now before i turn it
around to actually unbox it the proper
way i do want to show you the
certificate that's in this
because
again a very limited piece right
extremely limited piece
this is it from queen studio
collectibles thanos one quarter statue
and you get two head sculpts with this
as well right that's part of the premium
collection
this is your official certificate from
queen studio on that
very nice and it comes in like like a
hard piece of plastic which is good so
it's not going to like wrinkle up this
is really good stuff
okay so we've got that here
then let's put this to the side and then
let's turn this around
oh man this is big i actually think we
need a larger omni desk what do you
think
okay
okay
oh holy cow we this table is way too
small for this unboxing
we need the big omni desk
okay randy here we go oh
you huge come on you can do it you do
arnold schwarzenegger too
this
package
is just as badass in a way it's got
these velcro straps here
oh i love that sound
this is a strong velcro baby you can
hold on to like a car with this you got
buckles here you got the queen studio
logo here
randy this is legitimate baby this is
great
i just can't wait to see this thing man
this is just
so freaking impressive man
wait wait wait gloves gloves now it's
that time randy you know because
i don't want to touch any piece and
something goes bad
okay let's take off the top of this
randy if you could
hold this for me
holy
[ __ ]
whoa
wow
yo this is legit this is insane
oh
i don't even know where to start
okay all right all right i know where to
start this looks like it's
the base here
[Laughter]
it's so freaking heavy
oh
sorry guys i've never really unboxed
this is really a true first unboxing
okay i've never seen this in person i've
only seen an image
so
yo this is
crazy
heavy
okay
oh the detail
look at this guy seriously
holy cow
thanks man thanks buddy
wow
this
honestly
this is amazing
and that's the base next
we've got thanos
like most of thanos in one shot there
we've got the double bladed sword
oh it's a weapon this is a weapon holy
[ __ ]
this is nice
oh
oh guys
guys
look at this
oh man
this is legit
nothing plastic on this at all
wow
does it feel sharp
i have microfiber gloves on
it's hard to bring the tip it's not
sharp no it's not sharp it's not going
to cut anything but dude
imagine if like for a moment if hasbro
made of like a full-sized one like this
wouldn't that be cool oh
dude this is badass man
that's metal dude this is metal
it's a freaking metal double bladed
sword in this thing
hey can you hold this for me randy
thanks man what do you think of the
blade abby
it's good right you know why i'm
freaking out right now oh man thanos is
huge this is not for kids okay
okay so
oh sh how are you gonna help help me
real quick i gotta turn this around
yeah
because you gotta sit for thanos down
right
it was a hole in his ass
so there's there's a hole in that
thanos's ass you see that
so he sits
i'm nervous
oh
don't turn on me now
guys it's not ours to keep it goes back
so i don't want to damage it
oh okay this is like the most expensive
unboxing i've done all right
this is insane look at that just take a
look at this for a moment we haven't got
his damn head on yet and it's already
badass so now actually there's two head
sculpts with this right yes
okay so this looks like it's a helmet
here
look at this
look at this
the paintwork on this is just
breathtaking
it's even got
felt inside
so there's a scratch that knows his head
so he's comfortable sitting there all
day there's two head sculpts and i guess
we can take a look at it
which one we go for
oh
oh one pissed off thanos and one i'm
kind of happy thanos this looks
exactly
like the film josh brolin from the eyes
the sculpture the the chin
the eyes just glow they're beautiful you
know sometimes the thing is with sculpts
right
this is where a lot of statues can be
hit or miss because sometimes they don't
get the face structure right and even
though it sort of resembles the
character
it's a little off
this is perfect
okay so a little bit of a correction
here the helmet is not to be worn even
though it can fit over the head it's
meant to go on top of the blade so
thanos will not have a helmet on uh for
this so we're gonna slide it in here and
you just gotta kind of fit it's like a
puzzle ooh it's magnetic too
whoa wait a second wait no no no no
oh
oh it's magnetic okay so here's the
thing there's a magnet in here at the
base of this neck here and there's a
magnet inside here so that's how it
connects so actually you just slide it
in
and then it just sort of locks in
automatically
and there you go
because this is one thing i was worried
about is like how is everything gonna
fit in but if it's done by magnets that
just makes it even so much better but
look how badass this is zeno is it kick
is this kick ass
right dude this might be one of the best
unboxings we've done here this video is
brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lab
chairs especially the all-new 2022 titan
evo with its revamped 4-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support if pu
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely frost blue the titan evo is
even magnetized allowing the head pillow
to stick on the headrest without straps
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
secretlab.com
okay so now we've got this piece here
what you're saying is the base for the
sword right
oh man this is heavy as well too
ah there it is well even there's like
this leather inside of it to protect the
blade when you slide the sword in so
it's not going to get scratched
man the attention to detail look at that
you see if you're looking closer on that
you've got this leather in there
you know just one little critique so far
has nothing to do with the pieces that'd
be nice to have some sort of paper
instruction manual and i know queen
studios has a youtube channel where they
show videos but
if you don't have access to youtube
while you want to put this together it'd
be nice to have something here that you
at least could look in a booklet or
something to show you because like randy
what's this piece go to
i i don't know
oh it's magnetic too
is it yeah like that
it's magnetic as well okay
ah
all right so now it's sort of like
putting these little small pieces in
together right okay what's this too
yeah you gotta check it out
see instruction manual helps we just
can't rely on video because if our our
first service is down
and thanos was just delivered we don't
know how to put it together so here's
this other piece here and it looks like
it's some sort of railing or a bridge
that was destroyed let's try to look
it's like find the magnetic hole to put
this in
[Music]
it sounds wrong i know zacky i know it
does but just go with me
hey we found it this point goes in and
then it's magnetic
yeah that's it
young you figured it out thanks young
because everything is attached by
magnets which is cool so it's basically
just just debris in the back of it so
even when you look at this 360 the same
amount of detail in the front is in the
back and the corner everything is just
completely detailed okay so now we've
got these two pieces here and these sort
of complete thanos's outfit on the back
side of it uh i don't want to say it to
this kind of the skirt but the tails of
his outfit so they have magnets on each
of the sides here and
just kind of have to just bring it there
and the magnet will automatically sit in
to the hole i would say
this isn't that secure like the other
pieces are so far this might be the
pieces that you would probably
accidentally knock off first more than
anything because they do flare out a
little bit but
that's just my take on it again you're
not really going to pick this up once
you put it together it's going to sit
there and stay there but i mean if you
do want to move it around just be wary
that these pieces will come off
relatively easy because there's only one
small magnet holding it together but it
does give that it does complete the look
of the outfit especially from the uh
this is the rear and to the side of it
as well really nice attention to detail
okay now we've got this small piece
which looks again like another piece of
debris um i don't know exactly what this
goes to
again we have to look at the video
for that placement
somewhere around
and that might take me some time okay so
we found out where this piece goes and
it's right by the sword area there's a
slot with two magnets now
there's an argument to be made here i
mean one side you may say why even have
that piece
is it necessary and the other side will
say look
queen studio is going for screen
accuracy
they want this to be exactly what you
saw in the movie it's here
so
there's no right or wrong to this but i
would say a small part like that again
it is a little bit of a challenge to
figure out where these things are at so
as i mentioned a couple times already
instruction manual would be welcomed
okay now we're pretty much done there's
actually just this stand here with the
uh queen's studio uh plate and this is
where you can put the other head sculpt
on so you can switch out anytime you
want
wow
look at that look at that
that's his neck
his neck
whoops
nice
nice magnet strong and then this piece
goes
right
in
there
look at that
this stand is beautiful
look at the queen studio logo on the
back of that all just i mean the
attention to detail
they have done here
oh man that might be one of the best
stands i've seen
hands down
okay so now we're gonna put the sword in
this way here
and you just gotta really kind of just
ease it in there's leather so it's going
to be a nice sort of a
compressed fit inside so you just want
to push it to make sure that it's solid
it's
there it's not going anywhere then i'll
reattach this piece here because
uh didn't want that to
to scratch the sword anyway
yeah see this piece to me
i know go for screen accuracy but
yeah there we go so we sort of just lays
against the sword like that and then we
put the helmet on top
it balances
i guess like that
looks pretty legit by the way if you're
wondering how this table keeps going up
and down that's part of the omnidesk
thing it does go up and down and it
helps us with these unboxings so yeah
because you're probably wondering why
the table starts to load and go up so
high how did it happen
magic anyway uh let's just take a look
at this for a moment this is just
freaking phenomenal right isn't this
look at the detail from
the scratches the aging in the middle
around his
shin plates here
from the gold the patina if you look
around the side even the leather on his
outfit i mean you can just see the
crackles of the leather where it you
know it's worn down
the various different color tones here
we get a little bit of a
cyan blue and it's kind of like
just
it's just unbelievable and the sculpt
his sculpt on his face
the amount of detail and airbrushing and
paintwork that went into this
is
breathtaking
you know this comes in at 1 499
singapore dollars right and then this is
obviously going to be for the ultimate
fan
but
and this is the collector's piece look
there's only 776 made in the world
it is
uh authorized by marvel they've got the
license for it
and
i mean
i have to re-watch end game a second you
know or to just kind of re-look at it
but
i'll tell you what this is friggin
beautiful
this is stunning i don't even know how
you can review something like this i
guess you could say we talk about the
sculpt but the sculpt is dead on you
know the double bladed sword's metal i
mean just the attention to detail is
just it blows my mind you can see some
of the parts in the back of it okay that
you know got to put it together
it's a little bit finicky in that regard
but it's not that many pieces so it's
not going to take you that long to do as
a matter of fact i mean this is the
first time i've
seen it you know and we did it pretty
much in this in video minus you know a
few cuts here and there but
yeah man
this is legit i will say though for this
weight
if you've got something like a display
cabinet depends on your display cabinet
if you can hold the weight or not that's
something you definitely do need to
check because
this is really heavy 35 kg some will
some won't i definitely think this
should be on a table or should be on
some sort of mantle piece that can hold
it yes on the boxes 14 and up
but this is not a kid's toy or a kid's
statue by any stretch of the imagination
these are metal this is metal this can
hurt somebody a lot of these pieces are
you know have some not sharp edges but
more pointy just because it's that
shrapnel that debris that happened in in
the film so
yeah man i i i'm blown away by this
thing man i am absolutely blown away and
i know queen studios also makes various
different characters not just marvel not
just thanos also some dc characters as
well
and uh you know you can take a look at
their facebook page and also cultures
art facebook page as well they'll show
you some of the other products they're
bringing in
but if you're a marvel fan and you're a
collector
and you have the means
oh hell yeah get this thing you gotta
get this thing i mean
we should have this in the geek culture
studio we should have it
we just have nowhere to put it
but we should have it
as a matter of fact i would host all my
videos with thanos next to me
if we had it here
even though i'm talking about cameras it
doesn't matter i'll just shoot thanos
how do standards look 50 megapixel 60
megapixel hundred megapixels thanos
you're looking good baby looking good
anyway those are my thoughts
on thanos from avengers end game from
queen studios big thanks once again to
randy from collector's arc for bringing
this over for allowing us to unbox this
um any questions you guys have hit us in
the comments section below we'll try to
answer them as best as we can otherwise
we'll ask randy to help us out with that
but uh i think
this
says it all
it's just freaking badass abby you've
been quiet this entire time what do you
think of this
i don't know what to say to that
anyway thanks abby for that i know she's
writing a lot of articles right now for
us but with that guys take care stay
safe follow us on facebook subscribe to
us on youtube and we will see you very
soon take care
[Music]
you